彼女銀取り続けてるのさせん一切行っておりません今日の遊び雪をです桜もうラッシー
したことありますか
かっこいい言葉で言うと失禁というんですけども人は生きているとスイムを取り込んで
その栄養素となんと過去飛び込んで余ったさ埋設物を尿だったり便だったり体を外に
排出するんですけども1前例というものはなぜかと会に行ってちゃんと new
そうとか排泄物を出さなきゃなんかこう
汚いんですよさて目の事言ってるんですけどこうネットでお漏らししたりさあうん茶話
会てきたら
ヤバイでしょう失禁と呼ばれるそのおもらし行為がなんとアナアートですね失禁という
おもらしこういう体験できる装置があるみたいなので借りてきました
なんでかけたんだろうはいこちらです
あの結構禍々しいですは女が普通時限爆弾みたいな装置なんですけどいやいや相当
やべえよこれちょっとはねえええ
ちょっとメカニックすぎるんだけど
おっはー
なんかも
怖いんだらなんかも強いんだけどなんでこんな家族だが
うーんこうはダメだねこれは電源ですね禍々しいはなんて表現したらいいのかわからな
いってくらいすごいやばそうですね
普通に本気ですね
なーやばいサイト見たらファ
女の人がハマったししてくれえええええっ
やっぱりパン飲料は私たちが生きるために必要ですしかし突然の尿意に襲われ周囲に
トイレがなかった場合あなたの選択肢は一つしかありません介護教育とかにも使える
っぽいですね信金に悩む方の気持ちを理解するとか
医療の現場とかで排尿誘爆を行い1位の補助器具としてどうやって使うんだこれ
尿意を感じにくい感じられない人のリハビリ器具とし使えたら確かに
確かエンターテインメント出勤を楽しく学ぶためのエンターテインメントの力阿蘇笑う
のではなくともに笑うそんな新人体験をデビューしましたしね
失敬したい人馬鹿にするの俺もどうだと思うんですよね誰だって配慮しますから二年前
にはなかったら失禁ぐらいしますよ
電気通信大学の失禁研究会という組織が作ったらしいです何してんのって結構いる
ねしっかりしてて凄いですねじゃあちょっと装置の説明からいきましょうか
まずこの時限爆弾みたいなこれ水とあったかいお湯を入れて尿に近いオンボを出す
らしいですね僕は大学1年のときコンビニでバイト知っている時に失禁したことあるね
意外と近い覚えてナンです失禁冷たくないんですよあのオーラ視した時な高温かい感じ
がかなり服
外観があるんでそれを出すためにこの水とお湯で尿に近い温度を出します
そいつ体に取り付けてみましょう間で取り付けていこうと思いますけど
装置がマハマがしすぎてすごい管ついてるんですよ
本体があったらいいのが増えて
人ぽい感覚に襲われるんだと思いますわー
おもしろアームでレンタルするのにがちだ失禁の体験できる装置があるんだ
おもろそうぐらいの感覚で帰ったらなんかめっちゃ本気なんだからきてる気がするぞ
マジでわかんないの翼でどういう仕組みなんよしよしよし
ファーストステップはクリアした気がしますねここすっ黒になってて方向が暴走する
感覚をこれだぞい
美味しいです俺の考えた巧打の多分寝るこうついており気がしますこうだ絶対コーナー
出る長があるから ok さげですわねこれます直下お漏らしするからな
足回りに水が流れるようになるのでこれで決まり咲きましてきました
これあってるの多分エコーは ok ですこれでこの
漏らした時のちょって感じがこ
に体感できると俺が最後に下ろしたのは大学1年生の時ず米約9年の月日が経ち再びま
漏らそうとしていますやっていきたいとおもいます
どうぞ
もう何がまずメカニック過ぎてスゴいんだけど安いッスね
見えますかね温度が35.3度だいぶ太陽に近いで結構リアルな尿ですまずはこのそう
つ一つで尿が体験できるということだねぇ
さっさー村島
一人をすればいいんだろうでくれいいかいます
はい
[音楽]
うわっ
うぁああああああああああ
naa
rar
やばいやばいやばいわ
をガンダー声夏バーイ
うまいわー
はっはっは
やばい
[音楽]
今日はお腹がすごい信号するんですよ変化も声が一応あってねっこれ
これじゃ4
あっヘッドやばい
[音楽]
ん
いやだわ8枚まずで冷や汗かいた
スタールかなうーん
ません見てこの日合わせ分かりますめっちゃって書いてるんですよ
やばいマジで漏らした感じに襲われちゃいましたねこれ久々に大学生の時なんですけど
ここはすごいにかなり太陽に近いんでめっちゃ l ねそのようにもれちゃってた
ズボンのここにず追ってくるこの占める
生暖かく占めるこの感覚と暴行
がぐっとなる感じがめっちゃリアルねー
鈴木あってくれました
[音楽]
voodoo
学科失禁っていう経験はなかなか少ないと思うんですけども誰しもが一度はあるでしょ
おもらしこの失禁マジを寝てる人にバレーないようにつければ踊ら指数等も大変できる
だけなかなか寝ると起きない後輩がいるのでそいつに今日はおもらし体験してもらおう
と思いますこの湿気掃除を使ってねー
レッツゴー
eme
ん
[音楽]
ブーン
んはいありがとう
準備加入するで早速実験されて良いなと思います
ん
はぁっ
いっ
を
なぜおはよう
cap
そこん
何度なくっ
3位
me
ん
でもマシですかね
文字所